so big problem for soldiers in Iraq and
Afghanistan very few of them can speak
the native languages you can hire a
translator but that's pretty expensive
Raytheon thinks it has a more efficient
solution this is called trans talk it's
a mobile application in this case it's
loaded on to a motel or motorola atrix
so it runs on Android and basically what
it is when I speak a question that might
be tactically relevant to a soldier in
Iraq and Afghanistan it can speak back
the equivalent sentence in Iraqi Arabic
Pashto and dari so we'll give it a
chance now right now help on my friend
who paid from Raytheon how is security
in your village now he's gonna take it
luckily I'm not their hobby does anyone
in your village need medical attention
Killick idea holography edematous
oratory so Raytheon hopes this will
eventually be available in the Army's
emerging application store called army
marketplace and perhaps if you don't
have access to Google Translate this is
a potential solution for your
translation needs
you